can you tell me about a lawyer who
walked around and found out I'm sorry I
can't find the information I'm only up
to date through 2021. I have the
information right here
oh so AI is going to replace lawyers
well not anytime soon because it finally
happened we've had our first sighting of
AI lawyering in the wild and it was
um
it was bad
it was very very bad two lawyers in New
York deputized chat gbt to do their
legal research in an airline tort case
and found themselves in a direct flight
to sanctions land courtesy of one very
pissed off federal judge these guys may
have ended their legal careers for a
case which was always Dead on Arrival
and along the way they became internet
famous bringing the entire legal
Community together to point and laugh as
one so thanks guys so our Story begins
back in August of 2019 on flight 670
from San Salvador to New York's JFK
Airport passenger Roberto Mata claims
that an employee of Avianca Airlines
quote struck him in his left knee with a
metal serving cart causing him to suffer
severe personal injuries in February of
2022 Mata sued in New York State Court
alleging that he suffered quote Grievous
and painful injuries to his body and
Limbs and damage and injury to his
nervous system and became sick sore lame
and disabled causing him to be
incapacitated which is a lot of hassle
for a bag of pretzels and warm Sprite
now Avianca removed the case to Federal
Court immediately which means that the
New York County Clerk took no action and
simply transferred it to the southern
district of New York which is a federal
court where the suit was assigned to U.S
District Judge Kevin Castell not every
case qualifies for what's called Federal
removal but here Avianca cited multiple
separate grounds for article 3
jurisdiction to get it into the federal
courts now first international flights
are governed by something called the
Montreal Convention in international
treaty signed by the US government and
second the parties are what's called
diverse because Mr Mata is a citizen of
New York and Avianca is headquartered in
Bogota Colombia federal courts have
original jurisdiction over cases which
implicate International treaties and
they have diversity jurisdiction when
the plaintiff and defendant are not from
within the same state so this suit was
clearly one which could be heard in
federal court in New York now the
Montreal Convention is an international
treaty signed in 1999 to standardize
legal protections for air Travelers
mainly by regularizing compensation for
lost luggage but it also contains a
two-year statute of limitations reckoned
from the day of arrival at the
destination and you'll note that
February of 2022 is more than two years
after August of 2019 which meant that Mr
Mata was probably out of time and out of
luck but immediately upon removal
Avianca filed an answer denying all the
allegations and mata's admittedly Bare
Bones complaint although the airlines
conceded that quote a Roberto Mata was
listed as a passenger on Avianca Flight
670 on August 27 2019. in Avianca
asserted several affirmative defenses
which is something that negates Criminal
dollars of liability even if the facts
alleged are true so for instance Avianca
claimed that if Mr Mata was injured it
was as a result of either his own
negligence or actions by another
passenger but for our purposes we only
care about two legal issues raised in
the answer the first is that the airline
noted that it filed for bankruptcy way
back in 2020 in Mata as a creditor had
already missed his window to present a
claim for monetary damages to the
bankruptcy court and second avianca's
lawyers argued quote pursuant to article
35 of the Montreal Convention
plaintiff's claims are barred because
this action was commenced more than two
years after the plaintiff arrived at his
destination accordingly plaintiff cannot
sustain a claim under the Montreal
Convention now this put modest counsel
in a pickle because it's what lawyers
call Black letter law that they'd waited
six months too long to sue the airline
and that's even before you get to the
bankruptcy issue but luckily the
attorneys had an ace up their sleeve
because while the defense attorneys had
the law on their side the plaintiff's
attorneys had chat GPT now there's been
a lot of talk lately about the potential
for AI to revolutionize the practice of
law most famous obviously entrepreneur
Joshua Browder CEO of the online task
platform do not pay offered one million
dollars to any lawyer who would argue a
Supreme Court case wearing an earpiece
and speak the script produced by the
company's chatbot a version of chat GPT
that obviously never happened because it
was incredibly stupid which we've
covered on this channel now gbt stands
for generative pre-trained Transformer
and it's a type of large language model
in llm that scans vast quantities of
data and then is trained to synthesize
responses to questions using predictive
modeling now in its simplest form a chat
bot will answer your question by
predicting what word comes next based on
the information called from whatever
data set that it was trained on and chat
gbt in particular is an AI chatbot
released to the public by the research
laboratory open AI in November of 2022.
the problem however when it comes to the
practice of law is that right now chat
Bots are still prone to what are called
hallucinations or if you want to get
technical they just make stuff up
sometimes and they can even be trained
to lie something that Browder actually
bragged about in December he tweeted
that he trained his chat gbt plug-in to
lie to a cable company in a service call
the AI just exaggerated Internet outages
similar to how a customer would a
customer who was okay with lying to
another human being I guess facing
blowback from legal authorities for
practicing law without a license Browder
eventually retreated and pulled most of
the offerings which could be classified
as legal documents off of his site and
although it's still billed as the
world's first robot lawyer but obviously
that wasn't going to be the end of the
matter right now lawyers are already
using artificial intelligence to sort
through reams of Discovery documents and
it's probably inevitable that one day
there will be models able to sort
through case law and statutes
effectively to help with legal research
but as Roberto mata's lawyers discovered
that day is not today because in January
of 2023 Avianca filed a motion to
dismiss the case citing the two-year
statue of limitations under the Montreal
Convention and the pending bankruptcy
now mata's lawyer Peter loduca filed an
opposition arguing that new York State's
three-year statute of limitations
trumped the Montreal convention's
two-year cap or alternatively that
avianca's bankruptcy told that his
paused the statute of limitations and
thus there was still time for modest
claim now as a lawyer I can tell you
that this is a rather odd argument the
Montreal Convention exists to allow
International businesses which operate
in multiple countries to standardize
their practices so they don't have to
worry about dozens of different sets of
local laws and would defeat the whole
purpose of the treaty signed by the US
government to allow individual states to
impose their own regulations and statute
limitations on the Airline carriers who
happen to sell tickets to one of their
residents nevertheless loduca argued
that Mata was entitled to file a New
York state court and thus New York's
three-year statute of limitations
applied to his claim he wrote quote it
was the defendant Avianca who chose to
remove the action to this court the
federal court at which point the action
was already commenced in a timely manner
both federal and state courts alike have
continually held at the Montreal
Convention does not preempt state law
remedies and that plaintiffs are
entitled to choose the Forum in which to
bring their Lane and in support of this
argument laducah cited several Federal
Court decisions including one from the
fifth circuit captioned varghese versus
China Southern Airlines and one from the
11th circuit called zykerman vs Korean
Airlines now Avianca is represented in
this dispute by a law firm called Conan
Forsyth which specializes in aviation
law and you can bet their bottom dollar
that these guys probably know the
Montreal Convention inside and out so it
might have come as a surprise to them to
read a quotation from the fifth circuit
saying that a bankruptcy filing told the
statute of limitations under the
Montreal Convention but as you've
probably already guessed neither the
varghese decision or the zykerman
decision actually exist
attorneys and neither do at least three
of the other cases cited in the loduca
filing and in reply avianca's lawyers
wrote quote although plaintiff
ostensibly cites to a variety of cases
in opposition to this motion the
undersigned has been unable to locate
most of the cases cited in plaintiff's
affirmation in opposition and the few
cases which the undersigned has been
able to locate do not stand for the
propositions for which they are cited
which is basically lawyer speak for
you're in huge trouble now you're
watching this video which means that you
already know that many of these cases
are not real now there are a couple of
possibilities here one is that some of
the lawyers could have asked chat gbt to
write the brief or portions of it and
chat CPT cited to fake cases the lawyer
also could have just made them up
lawyers write placeholder arguments all
the time and then scrap them when the
legal research turns out the wrong way
but given that the original brief cites
case names with real looking citations
it's likely that the lawyer just used
Chachi PT and just didn't check the work
that was generated now we'll get to that
in just a second and that's when all
hell broke loose because on April 11th
judge Castell issued a show cause order
giving leduca a week to hand over the
text of the decisions in varghese
zikerman and the Seven other cases
claiming to be quote out of the office
on vacation lodic requested and got an
extra week to produce the opinions now a
couple things to note New York judges
are in the habit of just scribbling
their answer on the motion itself New
York is just weird that way there are
some other jurisdictions that do that
too sometimes it's just easier to just
write stuff down on the thing that's
presented to you but also if you are
printing real opinions off of Westlaw or
Lexus or any of the other legal
databases that real lawyers use all the
time the task that was requested takes
about 20 to 30 seconds it does not
require an extra week to complete that's
what we call foreshadowing now a show
cause order or order to show cause is in
order from the judge that's basically
give me your best defense as to why I
shouldn't sanction you and that's what
this briefing was all about so on April
25th laduka produced an affidavit
stating that he was annexing eight of
the demanded decisions but that the
attached production quote may not be
inclusive of the entire opinions but
only what it made available by online
database which is um
that's not how humans let alone lawyers
talk
um it's the kind of thing that you write
when you're hiding something and he said
that he had been unable to locate the
zeigerment opinion at all uh and that's
not good either and in fact this whole
response is just nonsense it is
trivially easy to locate a federal court
decision particularly if you have the
case site you can download these
decisions off the federal judiciary's
website via Pacer you can get it for
free from Google Scholar you can take a
field trip to your local library and
pull the appropriate volume off the
shelf and snap a picture of it on your
phone if you want to and if you can't
locate a federal case that's because it
doesn't exist now let's take a moment
and talk about case citations now I know
this is going to sound incredibly boring
but I promise you this is going to pay
off in a huge way later on in this video
now a case citation is something to let
the corridor opposing Council know what
case you're citing and where and really
it's just three things it's a number a
couple of letters in the middle and
another number now let's start with the
thing in in the middle that usually
refers to the reporter in which the case
appears now a reporter is a set of books
literal actual physical books that you
can find in any law library that
contains a whole bunch of cases that's
generally what a law library is there
for it's a compendium of all the cases
that are out there and here we're
talking about Federal cases so if we
look at the fake Citation for varghese
it has an F in the middle and that F
stands for the federal reporter that is
the volume of books that contain all of
the federal cases in particular the
federal appeals court opinions and it
contains all of them and in fact there
are so many of them that the 3D refers
to the Third Edition of the federal
reporter I.E newer cases than you might
find in the second edition and older
cases than you might find in the fourth
edition and then the first number refers
to the volume so 925 would be the 925th
volume of the federal reporter like I
said there are a lot of these books and
then the second number is the page
number of the volume so 1339 is Page
1339 of book 925 easy you're already
smarter than these lawyers and since you
rarely actually look it up in the
physical book you just plug those
numbers and letters into a search bar of
a legal database or even Google Scholar
and Bam you go straight to the case it's
really really easy so basically there's
no defense for them not plugging the
citation in and finding the actual cases
and reading them and we'll get to the
completely fabricated opinions in a
second but the fact that they couldn't
even find one of the decisions is a
terrible result in and of itself in all
my years of practice I have never filed
anything without checking every single
case citation to make sure that it is
what it purports to be the lawyer's crib
from other lawyers all the time and you
can never assume that the prior lawyer
did their research you have to go back
read the cases and make sure that not
only do they say what they're being
cited for but that there isn't some
other part of the decision that's
devastating for your case not to mention
you have to make sure that that case
hasn't been overturned later on so the
fact that you can't find the case means
that you didn't do your homework the
first time around when this thing was
submitted to the court very very bad but
second of all if a cursory examination
of these cases would be enough to tell a
practicing attorney that they were very
clearly not real and not just because of
the bizarre pagination shifting fonts
and apparently handwritten characters in
the middle of the text as the opening
arguments podcast pointed out the
varghese decision supposedly out of the
11th circuit is credited to judges
Jordan Rosenbaum and Higginbotham and
while judges Jordan and Rosenbaum do in
fact sit on the 11th circuit uh judge
Patrick Higginbotham is a senior judge
on the fifth circuit and similarly the
plaintiff is described as Susan varghese
personal representative of the estate of
George scaria varghese and then a page
later as Anish varghese and any amount
of digging into these cases would prove
that they were fake not least because
the internal citations that is the cases
they refer to are mostly like the
zykerman case that laduka couldn't find
are just made up and it's not a
coincidence that the two real decisions
are upwards of 25 pages long single
spaced and in tiny font which is
generally how long cases tend to be
especially in the federal circuit court
of appeals in the fifth and 11th
circuits well the case is that the
plaintiffs cited uh clock in at around
five pages or less which is just about
the outer limit of what chat gbt will
produce and practically written in
crayon but avianca's lawyers at Condon
are professionals and clearly they
didn't want to kill the Lily here so
they just responded the next day with a
polite letter to the court saying quote
respectfully submitting that the
authenticity of many of these cases is
questionable so this occasioned a second
show cause order from Judge Castell who
was clearly good and mad at that point
and he wrote the court is presented with
an unprecedented circumstance a
submission filed by a plaintiff's
council in opposition to emotion to
dismiss is replete with citations to
non-existent cases six of the submitted
cases appear to be bogus judicial
decisions with bogus quotes and bogus
internal citations set forth below is in
order to show cause why plaintiff's
council ought not be sanctioned and the
judge went on to say that he called up
the 11th circuit himself and confirmed
that there is no varghese opinion and he
went through all of the bogus internal
citations in the fake varghese opinion
that loducas submitted to the court uh
he told laducah to show up on June 8th
and explain why he shouldn't be in deep
deep trouble now as a lawyer seeing the
mistakes made by these attorneys is
honestly extremely hard to watch because
it didn't have to be that way there are
great lawyers all over the country and
now my firm the eagle team is accepting
new clients if you've been in a train
wreck like these lawyers or suffered a
data breach or dealt with medical
malpractice we can represent you or help
find you the right attorney who can just
click on the link in the description for
a free consultation with my team because
you don't just need a legal team you
need the eagle team just click on the
link below so three weeks later luduka
filed an affidavit with the court in
which he explained that he'd done none
of the legal work on this case despite
his name being on the filings now that's
not terribly unusual it looks like what
happened here is he was acting as local
Council which means that if you're an
out-of-state attorney with a client I
but you need someone with a law license
in a particular State you reach out to
someone who sort of double checks things
and files the actual filings and loduca
explained that it was instead Stephen
Schwartz one of his colleagues at the
law firm of Levitt Island Oberman had
been responsible for the case from the
beginning only Schwartz wasn't licensed
to appear in federal court so when the
case was removed from State Court he
continued to do the work and let laduka
take the credit which is uh not a great
excuse even though laduka says he's been
practicing law with Schwartz since 1996
and had no reason to doubt his buddy's
abilities but the thing is as an
attorney you are responsible for
absolutely everything that has your name
and signature on it and frankly
avianca's Motion in March saying hey we
can't find these cases on West law
following the Court's order to produce
them probably would have prompted any
reasonable lawyer to check the case
sites himself before submitting them to
the court with a notarized affidavit
swearing that they were good and
laduka's affidavit was accompanied by an
affidavit from Schwartz Stadium that
quote it was in consultation with the
generative artificial intelligence
website chat gbt that your affian didn't
locate and cite the following cases in
the affirmation and opposition submitted
which this court has found to be
non-existent Schwartz then threw himself
on the mercy of the court for his
mistake in relying quote on the legal
opinions provided to him by a source
that has revealed itself to be
unreliable he explained that he'd never
use Chachi PT to do legal research
before and was quote unaware of the
possibility that his content could be
false Schwartz said that loduca had
nothing to do with his screw-up and that
he had quote no intent to deceive this
court nor the defendant he finished by
saying that quote he greatly regretted
having utilized generative artificial
intelligence to supplement the legal
research performed herein and will never
do so in the future without absolute
verification of its authenticity
Schwartz also attached undated
screenshots of him allegedly asking chat
gbt if varghese was real and being
assured that they absolutely were which
is you know again not how you research
let alone a ninth grade essay about
mating habits of pandas much less a
legal brief submitted in federal court
but by now all of law Twitter was losing
its mind and the insane spectacle
courtesy of Mike Dunford who uh popular
as this total debacle uh and judge
costell was volcanically Furious and the
next day the court entered a third show
cause order commanding Schwartz and the
Levittown Law Firm to get themselves
down to the courthouse along with laduka
to explain what the hell was going on
and why they shouldn't be all sanctioned
for their activities and he added a new
demand to know why they shouldn't be
punished for quote the use of a false
and fraudulent notarization in the
affidavit filed on April 25th because
some of the documents require that the
signature line be authenticated by a
witness who has demonstrated that he or
she is a person in good character now
typically that witness is called a
notary public and they've been licensed
by the state to verify with a special
stamp or seal that the document was
signed in their presence by the person
whose name appears on it and loducas
April 25th affidavit accompanying the
fake cases he submitted to the court was
no notarized by Schwartz which is weird
even taking into consideration that lots
of attorneys in New York maintain a
notary certification because every other
document in plaintiff's case was
notarized by the same levittau paralegal
but this document in which laduka seems
to take responsibility for what looks
like fraud on the court perpetrated by
Schwartz is notarized by Schwartz
himself and even weirder it's dated
January 25th not April 25th but as we
discussed the cases they submitted to
the judge were weird the formatting was
wrong they were very short they have the
wrong judges the parties are wrong and
the analysis is basically nonsense
basically getting caught siding to fake
cases they then took all that time to
write the cases out as best they could
it's hard to say but the lawyers say
that they asked Chachi PT for the
underlying cases and when they got back
a small amount of text they thought it
was giving them excerpts from real cases
which still is not a defense you need
the entire case to be able to be sure
that it stands for what you're citing it
for but that's beside the point at
baseball so it's clear that no one
checked or read the cases that were
cited when they wrote the original brief
and we also know that the fabricated
cases were not created until the court
asked the lawyers to look into them
which is bad it's extremely bad so at
this point it dawned on the plaintiff's
lawyers that something very bad was
about to happen the whole Squad of
outside lawyers entered their
appearances on behalf of Schwartz and
levittau on one hand in laduka on the
other and these lawyers very gingerly
suggested that if the court was in a
mood to postpone the June 8th hearing
they'd sure appreciate a few extra days
to get up to speed now judge Castell
tessily replied to Schwartz and
levidow's request by granting them two
extra days for the written reply noting
that the hearing remains scheduled for
June 8 2023 and his reply to loduca was
even more ominous stating Mr leduca is
differently situated for Mr Schwartz and
the firm he has availed himself of a
full and fair opportunity to respond to
the course osc regarding non-existent
case law and three possible grounds for
sanctions he is not entitled build to a
do-over so the lawyers filed their
response and they basically doubled down
on the theory that Schwartz was too dumb
to be mendacious and laduka just wasn't
paying attention and the judge then
called the hearing and made both of
these attorneys actually take the stand
and testify under oath oh my God now
before I get to what happened in court I
need to teach you a new word it's a word
that my German friends explained to me a
few years back and my God does it apply
here the word is friend Shaman in other
words to feel secondhand embarrassment
or to feel ashamed about something
someone else has done to be embarrassed
because someone else has embarrassed
themselves so with that new vocabulary
word in mind let's look to what happened
at the hearing and thanks to the Inner
City Press we know roughly what happened
in court and judge Castell asked laduka
to testify first so judge Castel asks
laduka under oath what was your
understanding of your obligation in
connection with your March 1 submission
under rule 11. La Duke responds to be
factual and truthful I relied on my
colleagues Stephen Schwartz with me at
Lev it out with levito and Oberman did
you do anything other than sign your
affirmation did you read any of the
cases no did you do anything to make
sure that these cases existed no then
Avianca replied I did not read it later
on the judge asked do you recall writing
to me you were going on vacation and the
court giving you until April 25th yes
was it true that you were going on
vacation no judge uh Pro tip uh boy do
not lie to the judge ever uh either
verbally or in writing just don't do it
because otherwise you might have to
admit that you lied to the judge under
oath the judge asked you did not see
this was a bogus case no you see that it
was in different fonts a little bit
larger who typed this I believe it was
Mr Schwartz and again I'll note acting
as basically local Council it wasn't
crazy that another lawyer was doing most
of the work here but uh when that lawyer
submits a filing and signs it they are
responsible for everything that's in
that filing ah boy not a good look and
with that background Schwartz then takes
the stand and judge Castell asks how
many cases have you done a thousand yes
how do you conduct legal research I
research cases do you read them yes the
judge asks did you prepare the March 1
memo yes I used Fast case but it did not
have Federal cases that I needed to find
I tried Google I had heard of chat GPT
all right what did it produce for you I
asked it questions about the Montreal
Convention or the position you wanted to
take yes for our position you were not
asking for an objective view but cases
to support your position I asked it for
its analysis
did you ask Chachi BT what the law was
or only for a case to support you it
wrote a case for you do you cite cases
without reading them no what caused your
departure here I thought chat gbt was a
search engine and uh basically what you
can see here is that there was no good
answer yes he has to claim that he reads
all the cases but he clearly didn't read
the cases here the judge catches him in
a lie and he basically has no defense or
at least no good defense here because
even if chat GPT was a search engine he
didn't read the underlying cases and as
a result he cited a bunch of fake cases
and on top of that the chat GPT
transcripts that were provided to the
court continually say that it cannot
provide legal advice and it's a language
model and cannot access real-time legal
databases or provide up-to-date case law
and the thing about case law is it has
to be up to date and then
later fabricated a bunch of cases
possibly using chat GPT uh and that's
not gonna save him here and that's why
the judge leans in did you look for the
varghese case yes I couldn't find it and
yet you cited it in your filing I had no
idea chat gbt made up cases I was
operating under a misperception Mr
Schwartz I think you're selling yourself
short you say you verify cases I I
thought there were cases that could not
be found on Google
six cases none found on Google this
non-existent case varghese the excerpt
you had was inconsistent even on the
first page can we agree that's legal
gibberish I see that now I thought it
was excerpts man you can cut the French
Shaman with a knife right now judge
Castell continues Avianca put your cases
in quotations you know what F 3D means
right to which Schwartz replies federal
district third Department no we went
over this it's a book that contains
cases I have one right here look
it's the federal reporter this is the
second edition it contains a bunch of
cases the things you're supposed to read
before you submit stuff to federal court
it's not a federal district and it's
definitely not the third Department
the judge then asks have you heard of
the federal reporter
judge us that's a book right correct
glad we're on the same page finally the
judge goes in for the kill one more time
and asks so you were the one going on
vacation returning on April 18th yes
when you saw the Court's order it wanted
to see the cases did it cross your mind
that the court checked for the cases I
wanted to comply and the judge continues
you told me that chat EBT supplemented
your research but what was it
supplementing I'd use fast case at the
beginning Chad gbt wasn't supplementing
your research it was your research right
yes yeah so the media has talked about
how this is lawyers using chat GPT and
things going awry but what it's really
revealing is that these lawyers just did
an all-around terrible job and it just
happened to tangentially involve chat
GPT there are no good answers here and
so the judge summarized at the end okay
some final comments I will be taking
this under advisement and entering a
written decision it's been called a
mistake but there's more the record will
reflect whether that put Mr Schwartz and
Mr laduka on actual note notice that
their cases were non-existent Mr laduka
was asked for the cases we know what he
did and Mr Schwartz did man I just want
to die and I wasn't even involved in
this case from Shaman man R.I.P now I've
always been skeptical about AI lawyers
on this channel but hey it can't be
worse than these two Mr Schwartz and Mr
leduca probably would have benefited
from today's sponsor 80 000 hours
they're a non-profit that helps people
find careers that aim at solving the
world's most pressing problems like
artificial intelligence might be and 80
000 hours has been researching the worst
case risks from Ai and they have tons of
in-depth material on their website about
whether these risks are real and how
seriously we should take them would an
AI cause existential catastrophe could
actually look like and what you can look
into doing if you want to help
contribute to making things go well
that's because 80 000 hours is a
non-profit that aims to help people find
fulfilling careers that do good and the
research suggests that people working to
help us avoid the worst risks from AI
might be a really great way to make a
positive difference in the world so if
you might be interested in contributing
to navigating the transition to powerful
AI systems being out there in the world
80 000 hours can help and their name
comes from the number of hours in an
average career 40 hours a week 50 weeks
a year for 40 years now that's a lot of
time and it means that your career is
probably the biggest opportunity you
have to make an impact in the world they
also have tons of other research on how
people can find the highest impact jobs
and do the most good all of their advice
and research is available on their
website for free forever so if that
sounds interesting you can get a copy of
80 000 hours career guide which distills
some of their most important Research
into one volume for free at the link
that's on screen right now or down in
the description you'll also get access
to their free newsletter with updates on
their research and high impact job
opportunities so just click on the link
below and after that click on this link
over here for more legal eagle or I'll
see you in court